but I really wish I had my hammer Emma
thought unique was made from this
special metal from the heart of a dying
star and when I spun it really really
fast it gave me the ability to fly you
know the hammer no I didn't write down
the hammer are you on your back no no I
spin it really fast and if it would pull
me off oh my god am I pulled off the
ground would pull me off the ground up
into the air and I would fly every time
I through you always come back to me
sounds like he had a pretty special and
intimate relationship with this hammer
and then losing that was almost
comparable to losing a loved one it's a
nice way of putting it will you go ahead
yeah let's have directed talk about what
CD flying that cargo and that stemmed
from we're on set playing around with
the weapons before we shot the scene
that was one line originally and the art
department just went mental on their you
know artistic collaboration and in range
all sorts of ridiculous weapons and we
were laughing about oh my god what the
hell is this thing and what the hell is
that
[Applause]
hey hey we know each other
he's a friend from work everybody
thought you were dead
there's so much has happened since I
last saw you lost my hammer like
yesterday so that's still pretty fresh
Loki Loki Loki's alive you believe it
he's like he's up there everybody that
quarry clip is so perfect they
completely nail that improv scene and
they actually did say that they improved
a lot of that so I'll explain the
warbound
in the context of the movie and the
differences from the comics it's a
little bit different but they do have a
lot of Easter eggs in no matter how many
times I think about it that Loki clip is
still funny
Loki look who it is Thor actually had no
idea that that happened he didn't watch
that it hoped probably didn't tell him
after oh yeah I thrashed your brother
pretty good banner tends to not remember
everything super clearly when he's Hulk
but if you didn't know there's a new
round of that Thor ticket giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on the video
announce a new winner at the end of this
but the whole thing about the warbound
in the movie is that this isn't a Planet
Hulk movie even though there's a lot of
Planet Hulk in here so the only real
warbound characters that they included
from the comics are Korg and meek
it obviously meek doesn't show up in
this it's just Thor trying to explain
this hammer and they've been saying a
lot about the actual tone of the movie
and how they try to play it a little bit
lighter with the more ridiculous big
Ragnarok things so it's a nice balance a
big WTF but also not taking it too
seriously this is the example of them
not taking themselves too seriously Thor
does have a very special relationship
with this hammer even Odin had trouble
taming it so it was like he was destined
to become worthy and pick it up like he
didn't choose the hammer as a child the
hammer chose him once he became worthy
enough so there's like a whole lifetime
of adventures that we haven't seen Thor
have before we see him in the first Thor
movie
within seconds Ella smashes that in the
film and though there's some questions
about how she's able to do that because
she's either worthy or - she's just
strong enough to break Odin's
enchantment and I think it's just number
two they just want to show you how
powerful she is but Korg just completely
takes the gas out of it when Thor tries
to explain what his hammer does ahem uh
no I didn't write down the hammer are
you on your bank no no I spin it really
fast and it would pull me off oh my god
and then he just completely deconstructs
Thor's relationship with the hammer in
seconds this crazy gladiator that you
wouldn't think would be so philosophical
turns out to be one of the deepest
characters in this fighting pit so this
is hole implied backstory for Cork and
they actually do get into it a little
bit in the comics but Tyga steals all
the scenes that he's in in this movie so
there is some cool warbound stuff but
it's not straight-up Planet Hulk like
you would read in the comics the way
they talk about the hammer though like
losing a loved one remember this is also
Ragnarok so I think is just teeing up
the idea that some really big characters
might wind up dying in this film albeit
not the a-list characters that are part
of the Avengers movies so Odin is on the
chopping block although you do wonder
who's going to be king if Thor's not
going to be king after infinity war
although that's kind of what I'm hoping
for him if this doesn't even get into
any of the Hulk stuff that they
announced so if you don't know they just
had the premiere of birth or in Kevin
Feige and Mark Ruffalo teased a whole
trilogy within the next three films so
part 1 of this three-part Hulk story is
Thor Ragnarok
part 2 and part 3 are gonna be both of
those next Avengers films so obviously
there's been a lot said about why they
can never make a Hulk film because of
the whole rights situation with
Universal and how that's just a giant
headache so instead of doing that
they're making a stealth Hulk film
inside of these other films which i
think is a pretty clever thing to do but
a lot of you picked up on the idea of
where Hulk is in this movie so he's kind
of doing the Thor thing where you shirk
your responsibilities you just give in
to your baser instincts it's much easier
to surrender to the big ring guy rather
than try and fight him all the time so
that's what he's been doing for the past
couple of years
he hasn't been banner since the end of
Avengers age of Ultron so it's almost
like banner when
vacation and let Holt take the driver's
seat and he's been having so much fun so
there's a lot of fun in here too
so I think the whole idea is that he's
getting that out of his system like Thor
is slowly becoming more king like and
responsible banner is getting more
responsible he'll find that balance
between green guy and banner by the end
of Avengers 4 so we can start
speculating on future Hulk stuff after
Avengers 4 but I would love to see more
Hulk in space movies if they do a lot of
the cosmic movies the James Gunn has
been teasing out the non guardians of
the galaxy space movies with different
characters I think Hulk and Thor would
be perfect for that they don't
necessarily have to show up in the same
movie though but a lot of you did ask
though there was this funny story about
Mark Ruffalo accidentally live-streaming
part of the Thor Ragnarok movie premiere
that wasn't quite as big a deal as
people made it out to be he accidentally
left his Instagram a livestream app open
on his phone
stuck it in his pocket so last night if
people were still watching his stream
they were getting a lot of black footage
from the inside of his pocket with the
audio from the first 15 minutes or so of
the film maybe not quite that much but
the feed cut out eventually and then
they deleted the video like he's the
coolest dude ever so probably somebody
from Marvel realized what was going on
and it's like can you please delete this
this is turning into a big thing but
there's a whole team of people from
Marvel that handle the actors and help
them with that kind of stuff so usually
when situations like that develop
somebody jumps on it pretty quick but a
lot of you been asking me when I'm gonna
post my review video the embargo is up
next week so I'll be able to post my
non-spoilery review I think it's on
Thursday but I'll remind people there'll
be more Thor Ragnarok videos but it's a
great film it's very different from the
previous Thor films so I think I've
talked a little bit about that I'll try
to explain when I post my review video
they do a really good job of balancing
heart humor and spectacle because that's
really what you do with Thor movies you
need some of those big spectacles but a
lot of it is so ridiculous that you have
to take it not so seriously like this
clip here so let me know in the comments
what you guys do have a chance to see it
what you think of it so far so some of
you internationally will get to see it a
little bit before other so please don't
post spoilers if you are seeing it
before other people there's a whole
bunch of comic book premieres this week
so I'll try to get through those videos
as fast as
possible but I have a new game of
Thrones new Star Wars the last Jedi and
a bunch of other stuff so I'll try to
get to that as fast as possible
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner shale please private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details you can click
here for more Thor Ragnarok and infinity
war and you can click here for all my
flash videos from episode 1 last night
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight